CCDA documents are assembled from templates,
essentially reusable XML components.
Templates are defined at the document,
section, or data entry level.
These correspond conceptually to
a paper form where the document as a whole consists of sections,
each of which consists of fields into which data is recorded.
Here is the CCD we just looked at,
but I have now also highlighted two references to templates.
There are CCDA template guides posted and I've provided a reference to one from HL7.
Templates have an OID,
a globally unique ISO identifier.
As you can see, the first has
an OID of 2.16.840.1.113883.10.20.22.1.1.
The second differs from the first only in the last digit.
Both of these are document-level templates.
The first defines a document header for use in the U.S. domain.
This serves a purpose quite similar to FHIR profiles
in that it constrains the document to U.S. specifications.
Here you can see that it specifies that there must be
exactly one realmCode and its value must be U.S..
It is more interesting to look at the second template.
This specifies constraints for a continuity of care document or
CCD in conformance with stage one meaningful use.
Here, you see that it specifies the sections that must be contained in
the CCD so that it adequately supports use cases such as transitions of care.
Each of these refers to a section template and
the HL7 site provides links to these more granular templates.
If you first click on the link to the medication section template,
and from it click on the medication activity link,
you get to this data entry level template.
Note that it in turn links to specific value sets such as the medication route.
Clicking on that link brings up a page listing all the routes
specified by the U.S. Food and Drug Administration.
It also links to specialized data entry templates.
This one is the medication information entry level template
that could even contain a pre-specified product strength,
form or concentration such as Amoxicillin 400mg/5mL suspension.
Clicking on its medication clinical generic drug link
shows that the specification must be made using RxNorm.